m
et
bonjour l'actualité internationale des
échecs
aujourd'hui avec de nouveaux invités de
ces derniers mois nicolas giffords qui
est déjà devenu une autre émission
bonjour nicolas conte soir et nicolas la
vallée bonsoir s'était fait un effort
nicolas donc qui s'occupe du site la
tour infernale tout à fait très content
de revenir bien avec vous ce soir voilà
nicolas qui est aussi déjà venu
plusieurs fois vous avez pu le remarquer
et moi passer tout de suite à
l'entrepreneur rubrique de la journée
avec donc l'événement de la semaine le
fameux tournoi de francfort
voilà l'événement de la semaine alors
nicolas est ce que tu as suivi ce fameux
giants avec tous les meilleurs joueurs
du monde afin de forger je suis j'ai
regardé toutes les parties mais le
classement lui-même je n'ai pas trop
regardé je me suis concentré sur comment
jouer shirov par exemple qui me plaît
beaucoup kasparov bien sûr shirov avec
la particularité de finir son tournant
au mexique
il arrivait en cours non mais c'est un
gros handicap accès l'insee le décalage
horaire mais je crois qu'il est il a
encore été fidèle à son style il a
vraiment fait exploser échiquier
quelquefois avec des revers de fortune
mais c'était toujours spectacle et il
est coutumier shirov comme ça de gérer
son calendrier de façon très curieuse
parce qu'à linares aussi je me rappelle
on était allé à linares et après la
remise des prix il devait partir le soir
même fait il pouvait pas rester pour la
remise des prix parce qu'il devait jouer
en bundesliga
le lendemain il sait que c'est curieux
quand même qu'ils se préparent pas
absolument pour des événements je m'en
tiens avec kasparov shirov c'est
peut-être le joueur le plus demandé par
les organisateurs parce que bon on sait
que comment il joue il est tellement
extraordinaire à avoir joué que voilà il
est sollicité de partout ils essayent de
répondre positivement par tous donc et
voilà ça arrive sur bouquet on s'en
plaindra pas parce qu'il jouait au sénat
je crois qu'avec aussi le contentieux
qui l'opposent en ce moment avec
kasparov krainik je pense qu'il voulait
pas louper un événement comme celui-là
bon là y'avait casse parfait kramix y en
a mais vainement il voulait prouver
peut-être quelque chose si un petit tu
peux rappeler effectivement ce
contentieux nicolas c'est intéressant
bah oui puis fonce coûte beaucoup de
gens ont suivi ça c'est vrai que
g unique il ya eu un match qu'on appuie
sur le net entre chronique et shirov
shirov a explosé chronique sur
l'échiquier bon c'est vrai que shirov
c'est la bête noire de chronique est
donc bon bachirov avait été comment dire
le candidat pour le match de championnat
du monde donc organisé en 4 e garry
kasparov et shirov et puis pour des
raisons plus ou moins obscurs de
sponsoring sans vouloir entrer trop dans
le détail le match n'a pas eu lieu et
finalement c'est cramique qui revient
après après le choix en fait
dan hand qui lui a refusé par contre de
jouer contre kasparov donc shirov je
pense qu'elle a eu un petit peu mauvais
s'est senti humilié par kasparov le fait
que kasparov et refuser enfin n'ai pas
fait le match et surtout lui donner un
peu comme consolation un match un peu de
séries b on va dire contre toute visite
dans le gard il était un peu jédir
vis-à-vis de lui c'est un peu humiliant
lui s'estime est le challenger légitime
de kasparov et donc effectivement comme
dit nicolas il est ultra motivé pour
montrer que c'est lui qui sait le joueur
quel plus d'intérêt vis-à-vis de mon
match le problème c'est que c'est un
joueur qui sera meilleur beaucoup mieux
afin de bien meilleurs résultats en
matches qu'en tournoi en fait un tournoi
il pour l'instant il enfin sauf sarajevo
où le tournant fabuleux c'est vraiment
match il est extraordinaire il pulvérise
ses adversaires judit polgar par exemple
il l'avait battue je sais plus combien
cinq et demi 1 me -16 à une autre époque
olivier rooney qui était très très fort
qui avait battu talent match et s'est
fait écraser par shirov aussi sur un
score de
monstrueux parce que shirov nul qu il
connaît pas on ne met devant un
échiquier il faut qu'ils gagnent donc
même s'il mène dans un match avec trois
ou quatre victoires l'avant s'il va
quand même continuer pour enfin pour
pour jouer tout simplement donc avait
alors pour le score il ya tour il y
avait donc plusieurs tôt fait de tourner
à francfort donc le giant avec les six
meilleurs joueurs du monde donc shirov
donc avec kasparov krainik anand shirov
nos rosés beach et peter l'écho qui
revenait d'ailleurs depuis linas reste
puisqu'ils avaient pas jouer et donc le
ton à b entre guillemets donc où il y
avait ce qu'il appelait le master savait
qu'à la suite du classement finalement
puisqu'on retrouvait ivantchouk adams
topalov bas relief donc fin tous les
filles d'aujourd'hui monde était là
c'est clair là on peut peut-être parlé
un petit peu statistiques si tu fais
bien sûr c'est intéressant
quant à des informations j'ai quelques
petits résultats assez intéressant
notamment bon d'un point de vue partie
décisive élu 16 parties gagnées sur 30
16 parties décisives vous rendez compte
c'est quand même exceptionnel sur
l'information du jour rapides ces 25
minutes c'est pas du jeu lent c'est sûr
mais rappelle temps un petit peu ce que
disait capable en cas au début du siècle
bon tu me diras de nicolas si si je me
trompe mais bon c'est capable en cas
disais oui on atteint un tel niveau
qu'aujourd'hui les parties se dirigent
sensiblement vers la nulle
oui disait ça avant de perdre contre
avec il a perdu contre avec in alors si
on regarde un petit peu le classement
donc premier un hand in hand qui gagne
le tournoi avec sept points et demi ce
qui est quand même extraordinaire 7
points et demi sur dix on regarde un
petit peu les cinq victoires dont 5
victoires 5 nuls trois villes trois
victoires blanche et deux victoires noir
c'est quand même un super résultat à
sept mois et demi sur 10 1 on peut
regarder les joueurs contre qui la gagne
est bon il a fait 2-0 contre morizet
beach qui quand même un joueur au style
hyper dynamique hyper tactique et il a
fait 2-0 qu'on tire offre donc en semi
rapides quand des tacticiens comme chien
offert aux îles
je crois dans le parcours d'un land là
il fallait qu'il fasse un résultat comme
ça parce que les temps dernier et bien
il était plutôt très décevant
est-ce que c'est aussi est-ce que c'est
pas aussi encore une fois
quelque chose qui va décrédibiliser le
match gastronomique fait qu un homme
gagne ce tournoi parce que ça c'est un
un tournoi de ce parti de 25 minutes
c'est quand même très différent
et puis non quand je pense que cramique
en partie l'ongle ces derniers temps
étaient nettement supérieurs à attendre
et à shirov peut-être aussi enfin shirov
- mais en tout cas cram dit que
effectivement c'est actuellement je
pense le challenger avec shirov le plus
dangereux enfin si toutefois il est un
joueur qui puisse être dangereux pour
kasparov
en tout cas il va se préparer c'est un
gros travailleur cram nique et c'est
assez légitime bon sportivement qui
jouent contre kasparov si on oublie les
promesses qu'il avait faites à
sherbrooke bien sûr mais d'un point de
vue sportif je pense que ce sera quand
même un bon match alors le second
kasparov
quand même le king donc une belle
deuxième place l'année dernière quand
même une bonne alors au torse et voilà
il fait 6 points sur 9 6 points sur 10
pensent carrément un point et demi
derrière un nombre c'est quand même
extraordinaire je pense pour remonter à
combien combien de temps avant de voir
un résultat de kasparov a déjà une
défaite de kasparov
il a perdu contre les qhs autres et puis
une autre donc c'est vrai qu'on effectue
temps les coûts rachel battre on
s'attendait pas longtemps qu'ils
n'avaient pas perdu 4 victoires avec les
blancs et
2 avec les noirs c'est quand même un
joueur qui est aussi musicale qui
noircissent échoué contre piquette nous
semble un le tournoi sur internet oui
oui sur internet c'est le prix qu'a ce
parterre distance ne s'était pas devant
un échiquier et à sa star ouais enfin
c'est quand même des parties longues
alors alors 3e
on est troisième alors grave ni quand
même donc quelque part ça ex-aequo et
kasparov
alors non il a cinq et demi et il a
exactement il a cinq points une victoire
une défaite et que des nuls derrière
donc bon on peut dire qu'un petit peu le
match entre kasparov et crame ni quand
même et à noms des premiers mais il veut
pas faire le match donc on prend bien
les deux une deux qui suivent kasparov
et chronique il ya quand même une
certaine légitimité derrière ce que
shirov bon malheureusement il est
derrière
il est derrière krainik donc même si en
match il est horrible bon bah cette fois
ci c'était s'était pas ce à quoi donc
shirov quatre points et demi alors 4
victoires 3 défaites
quand même quelque chose aussi on voit
un kramnik qui fait une victoire une
défaite 8 nuls shirov 4 victoires 4
oui c'est ça exactement henry et roanne
et trois nuls pardon donc deux victoires
effectivement
blanchet de plus trop vite voilà c'est
ça donc bon on retrouve le shirov au
style vraiment sans compromis quelqu'un
qui est prêt à balancer une pièce sur
l'échiquier enfin c'est quand même
quelque chose de grand trouve très
souvent ça sur les parties de kirov faut
toujours qu'ils sacrifient quelque chose
se sont dit le départ exactement
donc ensuite on trouve on trouve l'écho
avec trois points et demi donc les
coquilles qui a énormément souffert avec
six défaites deux victoires seulement
donc les co qui a quand même gagné alors
c'est une particularité il a gagné
contre g [ __ ] kasparov
oui contre kasparov d'ailleurs d'une
manière assez étonnante kasparov il est
rentré dans une finale qui avait l'air
de s'acheminer vers la nul voila il n'a
pas vu qui perdait une pièce à cause
d'un clouage je sais pas si vous avez vu
la position des parures libération c'est
tout bête
il ya eu quelque chose c'est vers la fin
hyper est morose et beach qui était pour
une fois le client du tournoi avec six
défaites et une seule victoire
donc ça c'est on n'est pas habitué à
main et prend des risques énormes je
crois qu'il joue d'une façon très
optimiste qu'on veut battre le style de
shirov bâtir son propre jeu pour
l'instant j'ai pas d'ajout baroque qui
est plus peut-être il se défend moins
ils attaquent moins que giro je veux
dire mais c'est d ouverture très
douteuse qui joue mort aux juifs souvent
par exemple la dernière ronde je crois
contre kasparov
il se fait massacrer avec les blancs en
jouant un truc très marginale des cas
que m6 ou g5 et puis sur ses seins qui
prend à ses cinq sais pas si vous avez
vu cette partie avec gros rock des
blancs qui joue gros qu'il se fait
massacrer en fait oui il aime bien les
débuts qui sont un peu les sentiments
est ce que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut faire contre contre garry kasparov
qui monstrueux dans les ouvertures
oui pour en revenir aussi au jeu
spectaculaire shirov on dit que c'est
lui qui sacrifie mai contre kasparov
avec les noirs je passais vous avez vu
cette partie sous la
alizée peut-être kasparov lui joue faux
pranger 6 vous avez vous atteint sur le
roc l'armée merveilleux mais bon c'est
avec les rough il se passe toujours
quelque chose c'est clair alors c'est
justement ça je voudrais rebondir sur
sur ce que tu nous dis nicolas c'est
vrai quand on regarde un petit peu les
parties shirov kasparov shirov avec les
blancs en général fait nul avec les
noirs il perd contre kasparov
aujourd'hui il arrive pas il arrive pas
avec les noirs il est
on aurait continué sur des statistiques
ni couleur alors tu as tu d'autres
éléments intéressants
tout d'abord avant avant d'embrayer
déterminer sur les statistiques
les résultats entre krainik et kasparov
encore une fois match nul que ce soit
avec les blancs ont vaqué noir il ya 3
du temps partout où je crois c voilà
depuis plusieurs années maintenant tu n
2 nuls font que des parties nulles que
des parties nulles d'une trentaine de
coups en général je trouve ça quand même
assez étrange est ce que tu peux nous
dire quelque chose
ils se battent 1 et se bat vraiment
mesquer c'est qu'ils jouent très
prudemment l'un contre l'autre
parce que dans leur répertoire
d'ouvertures il n'y a pas de créneau qui
permettent une partie trop violente
il joue quand kasparov par exemple je
vous ai eu 4 et que cram munich joue la
cécilienne variante fiche nikov c'est
normalement violent mais ils connaissent
tellement bien tous les deux que
s'ouvrit à une série d'échangés et il
arrive dans une finale nul je vous leur
posez c'est cela qu'on a l'impression
que cette ouverture va déchaîner donc le
match des three lions parce que cela
fait les séries voilà il ya une telle
préparation tellement loin que souvent
ça s'éclaircit ou en cinq minutes chacun
des beats écouter oric des finalement on
est frustré d'une partie parce que bon
il ya pas mal de gens si tu sais un peu
comment ça se passe quand on a des
résultats un petit peu qui sortait un
petit peu de la moyenne c'est vrai que
ça fait très longtemps qu'ils jouent
ensemble que des nuls et beaucoup de
gens qui disent oui mais bon il y avait
ce championnat du monde dans l'air donc
pour préserver un peu crédit car à ce
moment être effectivement les deux sont
surtout cramique est obligé de cacher un
peu ce qu'ils aient besoin de préparer
on dit qu'on l'a finissant sur les sur
les statistiques
puisqu'on va après passer la partie face
à la partie alors j'ai effectivement
d'autres résultats statistiques en ce
qui concerne le nombre de coûts moyens
joué par partie par joueur tout ça c'est
un résultat qui peut être intéressant ça
peut me permettre de savoir si quelqu'un
a un style efficace
si par exemple ils avaient un bon
résultat dans le tournoi au vu du nombre
de coupes qui joue ou d'art ou la
combativité de la combativité alors dans
ce registre vous
mais trier qui en premier qui d'après
vous c'est le moindre le nombre de coups
en moyenne sur sur ces parties morose et
beach parce que il prend trop de risques
et il a dû perdre rapidement beaucoup de
parties mozy vie c'est pas mal mais il
ya deux personnes quand même avant lui
il y avait une paire sur ce tournoi il
ya deux personnes
l'art en premier c'est quand toute
attente c'est kasparov
ah ouais c'est kasparov qui visiblement
était le plus efficace ou qui a dépensé
le moins nombreux de cooper partie donc
il a dépensé en moyenne 36 coups par
partie donc ça se faire quelques nuls
rapide alors il y la pâte ont fait non
non non pas de pas tant que ça et non
mais il est précis quoi mais il est
précisé qu'en ce voilà c'est à dire que
je pense avec kasparov avec les noirs
s'ils très bien préparés théoriquement
bombe à la personne son adversaire avec
les blancs aux patrons envie d'entrer
dans un débat théorique sachant que
kasparov et bien préparé donc souvent ça
arrive avec des nuls rapide en fait 25
30 coups sans que ce soit des nuls de
salon mais c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose qu'on trouve souvent enfin je
pense avec les paroles andy rapidement
sur la pour la suite second un monde
alors il sait pas encore si rafa tu me
dire c'était une ferveur qui finalement
font le moyen de donner exactement voilà
donc il ya un ratio qualité nombre de
coups qui est assez excellent avec
kasparov et 93e moreau évite donc là
peut-être que par contre c
la mêlant s'inverse en quatrième quand
même shirov suivi de kram [ __ ] le
dernier donc l'écho qui vole plus qui se
valent plus ou qui voilà peut-être qu'il
est souvent le fait de faire peu de
coups dans une partie ça veut dire que
le joueur gère son tournoi de façon très
sérieuse série fait des nuls de salon au
moment où il faut général ça que ça
signifie peut trouver là c'est les
parties de 25 minutes c'est différent il
ya moins nu le savon effectivement les
parties comme vous pouvez voir et
l'entente car ils ont tendance à
continuer de toute façon même si c'est
complètement égal ils jouent des coûts
donc je pense que un tournoi comme ça en
partie longue avec les mêmes joueurs le
même nombre de parties et elle serait
plus courtes les parties alors est-ce
que tu as d'autres aux stats il faut que
j'en ai d'autres mais le temps nous
pressent donc maintenant mais allons-y
on dit c'est intéressant je propose de
passer au masters oui parce qu'on a
quand même pas mal de choses à dire et
on reviendra sur les statistiques si on
est un petit peu de temps après donc les
masters ont été remportés cette année à
francfort par michael adams qui a été
qui est assez monstrueux sur le tournoi
puisqu'il gagne avec donc 10 points et
demi il a surpris le second rang avec un
point 1 point derrière lui qui auront de
choc en fait le leader la plupart du
temps du masters c'était ivantchouk il
s'est fait rattraper et dépasser à la
fin par adams mais il avait très bien
démarré mais les trois quarts du tournoi
c'était en dessous qui était seul en
tête
vous pouvez revoir la mission qu'on a
fait la semaine dernière donc on est
derrière francfort avec un reportage
spécial francfort avec une interview de
i don't shoot le soir du premier jour où
il avait fait un très très bon départ
votre envie aussi une interview de
varier fadas mais on retrouve aussi les
conférences de presse électronique
attendait tout le monde ça c'est
l'expérience confirme une période
extraordinaire pour lui depuis quelques
mois mais les gagner bordeaux il a gagné
à bordeaux
sarajevo il a fait un super tournoi 2e
et je crois 2e jean faire une perf en
arrière kasparov permet parfois là avec
deux points d'avancé sur les autres je
sais plus quel autre résultat il a fait
il a gagné un tournoi en angleterre le
raid baisse la wii
tournament vraiment impérial moi je
continue un super forme tout à fait
mesdames c'est remarquable confort
rapplique ça fait les deux championnats
du monde fis dès qu'il a fait on est
allé très loin c'est aller en finale la
première année et là il est en demi
finale donc jusqu'en demi-finale contre
à copier à mais il est extrêmement
affûté
j'ai l'impression qu'ils vont être
choquant ce moment est en train de faire
un forcing assez ça va lui aussi a gagné
à lvov juste le mois dernier récemment
également un tournoi très très très de
très haut niveau il n'ya pas très
longtemps où il avait très mal débuté et
puis il s'était ressaisi en milieu de
tournoi tu te souviens peut-être
stéphane et ils avaient fini très très
fort et pour pour obtenir la deuxième
place je me souviens plus le nom du
tournoi mais ça m'avait marqué il ya de
ça trois mois adams est vivante ou qui
vont être ou non je l'avais un petit peu
surnommé le guerrier en fait le
gladiateur un autre rookie les cas qui a
du mordant et qu'il est terrible c'est
un des joueurs d'ailleurs contre kiel
kasparov a le moins bon score aussi je
prends qu'il a du mal conseillé et
pizarro il a beaucoup d'idées il est
très créatif sur chaque ouverture il à
sa nouveauté théorique alors on va
passer on va passer avant je te coupe
tout de suite nicolas on reviendra
peut-être pas dans la partie on va
passer tout de suite à la partie de la
semaine voilà si on peut l'envoyer
alors voilà donc on arrive à cette
partie fameuse entre morrow et leach et
on en a l'eau justement on va retrouver
dans cette partie ce que tu disais une
cote intéressante cette partie pour ça
c'est le fait que bon et vite c'est un
joueur qui va beaucoup de l'avant un peu
qu'il regarde pas trop ce qui se passe
quoi il est si vive zoug en vidéo
je me rappelle un moscou en 95 au
tournant des créneaux linstar sont
organisées par la pca il avait joué un
grand ami du roi contre allende d'une
tout le monde rigolait dans l'est dans
la salle en se disant mais ça tient pas
la route la gambie du roi ce niveau là
surtout avec la variante fous ces cathos
deuxième coup on laisse faire échec par
la dame noire laurent blanc dès le début
est obligé de perdre le droit au roc est
en fait il avait sorti une partie
extraordinaire ils avaient massacré la
lande et il avait donc éliminé à nantes
c'était élimination directe donc envie
droit après quand on voit son répertoire
il jouer la défense figurines contre le
pion dame moyens que des ouvertures un
peu et pièces de musées ou des amis dit
ouais c'est ça voilà je crois qu'il
avait joué encore bill evans également à
sarajevo où était bien il avait joué un
gambit evans contre
contre bacrot contre etienne bacrot et
il avait fait résultat nul je me
souviens de cette partie très bien oui
tienne site est admirablement bien
défendu dans une position difficile
avait quand même pris l'ascendant et
finalement résultat nul
oui là c'est un joueur atypique disons
chez les jeunes russes s'il y en a
beaucoup qui joue de la même façon la
slave très solide et que les noirs avec
les blancs est bon je pense à bas relief
drief cramique même un peu c'est un peu
de tous le même style très très timide
on va voir tout cru tpiy on va voir tout
de suite alors justement comment oser
ville atypique va jouer contre à nantes
donc le vainqueur final du tour de
francfort donc il démarre classiquement
que son ouverture probablement la plus
jouée vite eux deux quatre jours singh à
part non rendre dans une sicilienne
cavalière trois cas laisser si des coups
normaux de développement sans les
cavaliers et là tout de suite ça y est
bondée vite je rentre dans une variante
secondaire avec le couffo baissé
effectivement il est rare que morose et
beach post le pion de la dame la d4 à ce
moment là parce que ça rentre dans les
lignes connues et l'uimm heureuse et
vite ch joue des petits systèmes un peu
décevant souvent c'était adam ceci je
crois qu'ils jouaient des petits
systèmes comme ça des siennes fermés ou
louvoyante c'est pareil quand la
sicilienne il refuse les grandes lignes
la plupart du alors l'idée de se courber
5 c'est probablement de
attac rosso limo de contrôler les cases
noires au centre pour les blancs puisque
le fou mais une pression sur le cavalier
qui lui même de contrôler ces cases est
ce que cette ouverture jouit d'une bonne
réputation
oui bien sûr une bonne réputation
surtout de solidité
les blancs ne prennent pas trop de
risques évidemment ici dix minutes
peut-être leurs chances de gains
statistiquement mais ses adhérents
confortable à jouer avec les blancs
surtout après que les blancs double les
pions noirs ans et 6 ans prenant foudre
en cavalier s'ils ont souvent ils
bloquent le jeu après et ils ont une
position confortable à jouer c'est une
ouverture qu on pourrait conseiller à
celui qui n'aime pas trop les débats
théoriques ou mais il faut aimer les
jeux ferme et souvent ça donne un milieu
de partie assez fermé donc si on aime la
violence si on aime avoir du jeu pour
les pièces il vaut mieux ouvrir le jeu à
lorient de continuer avec la suite
recommandé puisque c'est le coup g7 g6
les bleus attaquent les cases noires
donc les noirs contre attaque
donc m le rend fou sur la case g7 pour
contrôler la grande diagonale ici ils
veulent pas lâcher les cases noires au
centre oui l'autre coup possible c e 7 6
pour relayer le cavalier 7-6 par l'autre
qu'at elle donc l'autre coups possibles
6 7 6 le pion devant le roi pour que le
cavaly g8 puisse sauter sur cette case
voilà beaucoup de flèches
on va passer à la suite des coups dont
croque rapide du côté blanc donc ça
c'est parfait au niveau développement
nicolas oui alors il ya fischer contre
spassky au match revanche 92
je pense que tout le monde se rappelle
cette partie il avait tout de suite pris
le cavalier français 6 c'était la
première partie du match retour de
fisher en fait ouais enfin le retrait
92 des fantômes savait plus où il était
il avait pris tout de suite dans ses 6
mai le coup petit rock c'est le coût
normal de la théorie tout de suite en c6
avec la même idée que derrière
l'espagnol variantes des changes n'ont
pas exactement parce que se passe-t-il
par un peu avait repris du pillon
bessette
donc c'est pas pour le même problème
pions vers le centre alors fou g7 de la
part d'un land et là on voit encore que
sa lutte pour les cases noires puisque
les blancs jouent le coup c2 c3 avec
l'idée de contrôler la casse des quatre
ici et de jouer le coup de d2 d4 pour
envahir le centre c'est aussi mais c'est
un cookie contre le fu g7 ouais ça c'est
la vieille façon de jouer cette variante
on joue comme
joué par marc rozé vite j'ai encore une
fois donc la recherche des vieilles line
parce que la plupart des joueurs
maintenant comme à nantes par exemple
avec les blancs où ils veulent tout il
prend le cavalier à ses 6 toujours cette
prise possible du cavalier il suivi du
blocage par détroit et joue pas c'est
waou
il ya eu pas mal de parties de
ivantchouk avec les blancs
d'autres joueurs comme adams aussi avec
les blancs à jouer ça s'est souvent mais
de jouer comme ça c'est 3 pour pousser
des 4 sél à l'ancienne façon je me
souviens d'une partie vivante chaude
kasparov qui avait pas un cavalier ans
et 6 mai il avait fait foulée cinq
échecs dans une saison magnifique où il
avait gagné concret ça c'était une scène
ouverte qui ensuite avait donné lieu à
cet échange ne savait pas commencer par
une attaque rosso limon alors ensuite
coup logique d'attendre encore une fois
un sens une pièce car il ya six donc là
ça attaque tout de suite le pian 2 4
donc ça pose un problème aux blancs
problème qui résonnait encore une fois
par an vous évite une façon détournée
parce qu'on pourrait jouer tout le
coutour eu un cas l'air joli talent est
relogé ouvrirait lundi que soit le
coutour eu un soin tout 20 soit
éventuellement 1,5 soit éventuellement
pousser wc surtout vous allez vous
inquiet qui préférait par les
théoriciens et ben amor osez vite lui
choisi un coup très curieux dames 1 4
alors ça ce groupe nous a surpris et
nicolas quand on aurait là parfait mais
je connaissais bien effectivement tout
re 1 avec l'idée de faire des cats et
prend décès prend des puits les noirs
plus des 5 avec l'idée de mettre un
cavalier en 2 4 c'est vrai que damas
catch que ne l'est pas du tout je crois
qu'il y des salles web de menaces et e5
est que le cavalier noir ne puisse pas
aller angers 4 je pense aussi par
exemple et noir hockey il poussera elle
il y aurait pas le coup ko léger qu'à
cause de la dame
à mon avis ça l'idée est
la casse des cinq serait pas une bonne
case pour le baiia ensuite il ya des
remous kappa tacle qu'avec des saints
qui ça peut amener des suites comme ça a
su effective étant dieu on va voir que
tout de suite bien en europe qu'en lan
et mais bon si en cause par 2,5 alors il
joue des deux des quatre jeux vous des
deux des quatre alors avec l'idée qui
quand même curieux c'est que le pion 1,4
et attaquer nicolas on voit que c'est un
piège de beats c'est d'être un piège
puisque doit y avoir le coup des cadres
des singles qui est ensuite voilà en
case de prison peut-être on peut montrer
cette variante donc à deux prix du point
ici les blanches jour et le coût des
quatre des cinq attaques
le cavalier c6 et la dame à 4 attaque
maintenant un cas le cadre donc il ya
une pièce qui va être perdu tout ça
c'était l'idée de damas quatre en fait
c'était ça c'est est ce le piano
sibilité fasse pas rire ça permet de
penser au centre sans perdre de pions
alors il faut voir quand même si les
noirs échanges en des caps d'abord c'est
ce qui se passe avant c'est prendre des
quatre c'est prendre les 4 et là il peut
pas prendre un lancer capte aussi prend
il
il va avoir le même problème avec une
petite différence voilà il ya le coût
des cinq attaques le cas les c6 donc
avec le client et la dame en quatre
attaques de caudillos 4 les noirs pour
rejouer le coup intermédiaire car ils
essaient 5 qui attaquent la dame
une fois que la dame bouge on peut
bouger le cavalier mais le coup
probablement dame ces deux dames ses
quatre vingts dame c4 mc2a d'imbéciles
peut-être d'un v6 alors peut-être dame b
4 6 4 pardon dans ces quatre ici une
possibilité oui le cavalier ces six
tombeaux le cas
voilà l'annoncé de canal et tant pis si
lecavalier il faut protéger le cannabis
et 5 et le calice et si c'est sous la
menace d'un pion donc il va y avoir une
déco kabylie qui tombe donc six heures
ça peut c'est sensiblement la même
variante dames c'est qu'un tel coup
juste voilà donc finalement donc
maintenant ne tombe pas dans le piège
nelly malaise lundi et paris jouent 17
des six ces annonces qui offre un pion
maintenant certain qu'ils répondent plus
aux réflexions alors il faut commenter
ça puisque le puits le pion sait si ces
emprises le caresser si ces entreprises
et après bruxelles 6 pour reprendre le
fou devant la variante caylar s'il est
blanc essaie de prendre le pion donc ici
fou prend cavaliers et noir récupèrent
issifou au plus on prend fou pardon et
si la dame prend le pion c6 mais tout
simplement parce que le coût fou 17 qui
attaquent la dame ici la dame a pas de
case efficace pour protéger le piémont
quatre super g dames ces deux mais
peut-être il ya tour c'est 8 après qu'
harry peut-être un fait pas claires la
main peut-être le coup tout simplement
tourbe est vite tombé à 8 tout de suite
au lieu de fou 17 d'accord alors nicolas
butaud placé alors on va voir
donc il prend le pion prend qui on voit
la fosse et 6 puis on prend six d'un
prince et six et tu proposes le coutour
des huit pour faire pression sur la
colonne et puis c'est un vrai gambiste
d'ailleurs que les noirs estime que tôt
ou tard la chime menaces poupées 7 pour
reprendre le pire et 4 d'accord donc en
fait tu penses que c'est plutôt un
sacrifice dynamique en fait ouais c'est
un gambit cinq ans bits
c'est vrai qu'elle est noire vont avoir
une longueur de colonnes b paire de faux
et il va gagner des temps sur la dame
blanche donc il doit estimer que encore
occupèrent pas levé dans tout de suite
c'est pas possible je ne peux pas le
heureusement que nicolas est là pour
nous sauver
je pense mais bon c'est probablement ça
non après
après finalement le coup des six on a vu
des andes finalement les blancs ne
prennent pas ambiance et 6 mai joue le
coup cavaliers en c3 tout simplement on
a l'impression d'ailleurs que anand a
mal joué dans les coups précédents parce
que visuellement on voit la position
blanche deux clans magnifique au centre
qui ne sont pas contestées deux
cavaliers sorti le rock effectués bon le
fou ici et la dame sur des postes un peu
inhabituel mais quand même actif
on a l'impression que les blancs un gros
avantage oui invention que les biens
sont mieux la conception classique du
jeu qui qui qui dit ça alors que mais
d'après ni n'assure pas si simple si le
fou ici le fou g7 contrôle bien le
centre à distance et il faut dire que
les noirs ici me laisse pousser les
blancs on laisse pousser les blancs et
les noirs font une bonne pression quand
même sur case noire avec lecavalier le
fouet le pion des six qui contrôle bien
aussi la case 2,5 donc là elle est là le
maine le contrôle des cases noires par
les noirs est quand même bon alors ça
c'est instructif de voir qu'un joueur
moderne comme un homme accepte d'avoir
les noirs une position comme ça c'est au
premier coup d'oeil on peut avoir
l'impression qu'ils se fait écraser la
suite de la partie je crois va malgré
cette impression dans les premiers temps
là en dessous des 7 donc la logique donc
quand il faut alors là il fait le
développement de type dragon et nicolas
rey il est sur trois rangées seulement
voilà les pièces noir dépasse pas l'air
d'avoir du dragon la sixième c'est ça
voilà c'est ça alors mais en revanche
les blancs n'ont pas du tout le même
disposition de deux pièces notamment le
roi est en parfaite sécurité avec le
petit rock et ils ont deux pions sans
trop magnifique c'est dans la sicilienne
c5 effet normalement pour prendre un
pion central chez les blancs mais là les
blancs l'ont toujours leur plein central
des quatre n'existe pas dans dragon et
là il existe près de l'autre côté il n'y
a pas de colonne ouverte pour les blancs
sourd sur le centre non c'est vrai du
point de vue du jeu des pièces
les blancs n'ont pas amélioré par
rapport à une variante normale du dragon
mais en revanche au niveau des pions il
semble que les blancs et un gros
avantage
en tout cas au niveau spatial ont plus d
espace voilà le contrairement à la
variante conques ont évoqué les blancs
vont également voir jouer sur la colonne
c'est autant que les noirs en tout cas
alors en tout cas on va continuer parce
que là ça tente moreau évite justement
de pousser ses pions pour essayer de
mettre un peu la pression sur
l'adversaire et il joue effectivement au
10e coup le coût des 5-6 tout de suite
mais attaque le cavalier c6 donc pas un
problème au noir et on a l'impression
qu'ils rentrent dans le camp noir
oui c'est ça et puis il veut échanger
son fou en b 5 qui fait taper un peu sur
du granit et puis qui gêné par son
propre pion central en leucate donc
c'est d'un point de vue stratégique
c'est assez logique
on se demande quelle quelle case il
reste pour le pôle câble il reste plus
que la quasi vides et 8 m en ghilane on
n'a pas peur de remettre son cavalier
sur la case des huit ans boissons que
c'est un aveu de faiblesse un
saint-nicolas puisqu'on rom et son
cavalier sur la case de initial oui non
parce que là la position coup précédent
vient de se fermer comme les blancs pour
vous payer une sorte de blocage des
pions donc dans un jeu fermé parce que
les blancs les blancs auront du mal à
atteindre
il ya eu un petit problème
voilà je reviens les blancs
auront du mal à pousser le coût d ici eu
4 5 puisque les noirs contre le tr min 7
s de think we et les noirs ont le temps
finalement de remettre ce cavalier au
centre assez vite sans dommage et blanc
vont certainement jouer pour les cases
c7 peut-être et puis les noirs pour la
casse et cinq dans cette position là oui
c'est tout le jeu va se passer sur la
colonne ouverte c'est effectivement lors
la colonne ouverte si on me l'a montré
tout de suite ici c'est les cases rouges
que je vous montre la donc là les noirs
ou les blancs aussi de hollande occuper
cette colonne avec une tour
la position de cette colonne c'est un
enjeu stratégique pour les prochains
coups alors les blancs jouent finisseur
développement avec qufu et 3 il paraît
logique et libère la case c1 pour une
tour blanche
et voilà cette fameuse casser un
effectivement libéré maintenant soit
pour la tour 1 soit éventuellement pour
l'autre touré fin lune ou le tour c'est
l'avantagé d'avoir lié les tours c'est
qu'on peut choisir celle qu'on veut m et
là les noirs mais finalement pose la
question maintenant on fout des cinq
puisque ils ont envie de reprendre de
remettre le cavalier des huit ans je
peux être il joue le coup à cette a6 et
les blondes pas trop le choix puisque
s'ils sortent le fou c'est la dame qui
emprise donc ils sont obligés de prendre
17 et ça va réactiver le cavalier vite
or il aurait pu encore laissé un pendant
un coup le fou emprise mais c'est un peu
idiot parce que le pion à cissé est
cloué et le pion à 6 effet on ne peut
pas prendre tout de suite en d5 puisque
tours à huit la torah 8 serait en prise
par la dame donc c'est une séparément
une menace mais tu vois que les blancs
pour garder la pression il se poserait
des problèmes eux-mêmes en fait en
essence ce fou emprise peut-être que les
noirs pendant avec le fouet après la
reprise du cavalier les noirs sortir la
cavalerie b8 et le cavalier des cinq
seront prises c'est possible resituons
cavaliers pro 4 qui avait pendant quatre
qu'elle est embêtant un pur don qu'ils
échangent en dix-sept les fous ça c'est
donc food rend les sept cavaliers b
prendre 17 et maintenant on s'est vite
choisi le coût d'un b3 qui a pas l'air
de faire grand chose pour le
développement nicolas soutenu il annonça
reste la place au pion à 2 je pense
qu'il veut jouer à 2 à 4 pour gagner de
l'espace
l'idée probablement de jouer à 2 à 4
pour contrer en fait cette baie 5 des
noirs oui mais pour jouer peut-être
lui-même à 4 à 5 pour gagner de l'espace
avec dame fixé ses pions noirs ici et
ensuite faire des manoeuvres du style
cavaliers à quatre cavaliers b6 si les
noirs ne font rien donc voilà il dit se
replacent monde dames
mais c'est les noirs qui joue maintenant
dans ma 5e même avec l'idée
qu'effectivement si les blancs prennent
le pion baisse est tout simplement je
retour à 8 sur la case b8 attaquant la
dame et ensuite on viendrait prendre le
pion b2 donc on récupère et le plan avec
une tour excellemment placé dans le camp
ennemi
j'irai peut-être eu nulle déjà il y
aurait nulle part répétition coup je
crois aussi sur d'un branle et noir
pourrait imposer la nulle part tous
réfutent b8 widom ces six tours ces huit
dont 2,8 et dans cette position là
nicolas est ce que ce serait pas
justement l'intérêt des noirs de
continuer puisqu'il aurait une tour
installé sur la deuxième colonne blanche
le deuxième rangée blanche un fou g7 qui
deviendrait monstrueux c'est vrai les
noirs seraient mieux c'est nord serait
sûrement un peu mieux donc là les bleus
en continu avec un coût qui est fou des
quatre qui centralise bien le fou ou
alors c'est intéressant sous chevaux
l'air de bien rayonner puisqu'il y don
qui contrecarre un peu l'action du fou
ou g7 donc il s'oppose à lui et il
rayonne des deux côtés à la fois du côté
dames et du côté roy finalement c'est à
l'heure de troncs coup intéressant
positionnelle peut être n'aurais je
crois que les affaires des blancs ne
vont pas si bien que ça c'est pour ça
qu'il a joué ça parce que le coût normal
c'est de mettre une tour en c1
oui mais il a dû craindre quelque chose
peut-être le coup je sais pas ce qu'il a
craint enfin food etc est un peu bizarre
parce que sa menace rien c'est un coût
qui a l'air d'être craintif de révéler
que les blancs creil quand tu disais
tout à l'heure le problème c'est que les
blancs fermer la position un jour en d4
d5 et ils ont fixé leurs chaînes de
pions et peut-être
il faut quand même jouer avec les pieds
à ce qu'on est solidaire a je crois voir
si je crois vous à l'idée quand même
l'idée c'est sans doute peut-être de
menaces est maintenant de prendre deux
pions bessette et si la tour noire
ensuite vient prendre le plan b 2 il ya
le fou des quatre qui peut créer leur
menace de faire quelque chose c'est un
coup prophylactique oui sept non mais ça
me laisse peut-être le pion bessette
alors excusez ma tactique je pense est
une bonne idée nicolas puisque à nantes
a joué le coup b cette baisse indique
donc c'est peut-être en prévision de ce
que tu viens de dire
mais peut-être anticipé cette
possibilité c'est vrai que ça se voir si
les noirs veulent jouer sur la commune
c'est b5 et logique puis tout cas là il
ya tout de suite une menace du côté noir
puisque la menace cb 5b 4k tacle cavalli
c3 et le pion à eux quatre soirées en
prise par le khalife 6 puis s'affaiblit
la casse et 4,6 pour eux dans le camp
blanc un cavalier pourrait venir
s'installer rapidement sur cette case
oui cette case ici soutenu par une tour
éventuellement en s'est vite
ouais ça peut être un avant poste
possible sur la colonne ouverte mais
c'est vraiment pour l'instant cette
colonne ouverte personnes veulent
occuper alors il ya un inconvénient
quand même beaucoup b5 c'est que ça
affaiblit la casse c'est si voilà cette
quasi si fait que si le cavalier f3
parent vient à des cats il peut ensuite
cette case ici est affaibli donc
effectivement si on a les blancs arriver
à mettre un cavalier sur cette case c6
qui est pointée en verre il y avait une
seule case verte maintenant sur
l'échiquier être cassée 6-6-6 aurait une
belle place pour un cavalier
effectivement voilà en tout cas on peut
noter qu'il ya une menace blanche noire
pardon tout de suite donc ses deux
pouces et b5 des quatre le cas et c3 est
attaqué obligé de bouger et le pion à 4
et 30 prises donc ça explique le coup
suivant de nowitzki joutes tour f 1 e 1
protégeant ainsi cette case ce pion
leucate tout simplement avec la tour
mais pour l'instant toujours pas
d'action sur cette fameuse colonne
ouverte où il n'ya pas de pions où il
faut absolument mettre une tour mais on
va le voir que le ca y est les noirs
mais aussi m puisqu'il joue au coup
suivant le coutour s en suit le tour du
côté droit alors pourquoi cette tournée
quoi c'est toujours une problème de
savoir quel tour il faut mettre et bien
parce que la tour en a huit
elle reste active comme le jeu est
ouvert sur les dames
quand même une action où elle est alors
que si la tour était resté en fuite
cette quasi vierge et n'aurait aucune
action en fuite elle serait celle qui
n'a pas bougé donc le lycée à de
l'action
les deux tournois rond comme ça sont
dans un secteur qui est un peu chaud qui
est un peu chaud tout à fait alors coup
suiveurs maintenant deux morose et vite
il veut empêcher le coup b5 b4y joue à
deux à trois mais qu'à leur carrière un
coup sans idées quoi ont l'impression
qu'ils manquent d'idées en fait non à
l'idée du coup à deux à trois c'est de
libérer la casa 2 pour le cavalier blanc
je pense qu'un visage la manoeuvre
cavaliers à 2 pour le m finalement ces
systèmes cavalia 2 celui de karine et
des 4es car il sait s'ils voient la
possibilité d'idées donc plus que pour
empêcher beisheim des quatre oui voilà
l'idée parce qu'en fait des cinq bekkat
au goût précédent les noirs pouvaient le
faire et bronzé lui qui avait prévu de
jouer cavalier à 4 certainement avec
le contrôle de la casse b6 et ça aurait
montré au noir que bkt pas terrible
alors il a joué tour main pour laisser
les noirs poussé b4 mené noir ont décidé
que c'était sans doute son
affaiblissement
c'est très intéressant cette partie
puisque en puissant le pion en d5
on a l'impression que les bleus ont
donné pas mal de cas zones noires mais
en même temps il s'en donne puisque là
on voit on est un trou en c6 le saas et
des noirs qu'ils ont permis puisqu'ils
ont joué eux mêmes de cette décennie
c'est vrai si donc les noirs en lan fait
sciemment 7 2 or et cette case
effectivement il ya des avantages et des
inconvénients alors on va voir tout de
suite la suite à leur tour avait huit
effectivement l'intérêt qu'on voyait
tout à l'heure c'est que maintenant sept
tours à 8 peut venir sur la case b8
pendant qu'à tours s'éviterait sur son
poste et continuer à voir l'action sur
la colonne hélas cette tour soutient le
plan b 5 qui peut maintenant menacés et
éventuellement de s'avancer peut-être
plus tard en tout cas en tout cas les
plus actives ici que nulle part ailleurs
sur le sur la 8ème à angers c'est sûr
alors maintenant la manoeuvre cité par
nicolas effectivement cavalia 2 avec
l'idée de mettre sur calais sur la case
b4 et ensuite devenir sociales cass c6
protégé par le pion des cinq un cavalier
qui ferait une pression à la fois sur la
tour b 8 et le pion recettes et il
serait même sur la dame 1,5
ce serait un cavalier très très fort si
on jouait aux échecs marseillais où on a
droit à deux coups de suite cavaliers à
deux ans et six de ses sites marseillais
ça gagnerait paul sagan hier la partie
tout de suite donc cesser une menace un
terrain c'est une manoeuvre intéressante
de monrose et mitch alors un an de
contrat car cette manoeuvre tout de
suite avec le coup cavaliers en c5 qui
crée une menace tout simplement
s'attaque la dame b3 et s'attaque aussi
le pion aux 4 est maintenant sous le
prisme du cavaliere 6 et du cavalier 5
oui donc le dernier coup
de morose et vite chez ces responsables
parce que ça laisse faire ce coup
cavaliers c5 qui laisse pas de choix aux
blancs et blanc doivent prendre ce
cavalier
alors quand ces 5 partis veulent pas
jouer un coup comme par exemple
notamment eu droit qu'à l'ère de nancy
la mission centrale ont pris l'option
centrale sera reprise effective donc il
pour ne pas perdre un pion les blancs
sont obligés de donner un fou qui a
l'air assez puissant et puis en plus
après cet échange les noirs ont le choix
de reprendre soit avec la tour soit avec
le pion des cinq ans voit tout de suite
effectivement cole et blanc prennent
donc ils sont obligés et la n12 choisi
de prendre avec le pion alors c'est très
risqué
c'est très risqué oui parce que ça
laisse les pions blancs sans trop
s'avancer voilà c'est ça libère tout de
suite les pions il était bloqué
maintenant on voit que le pion eu qu'à
peut avancer 1,5
il est plus gêné par pions des 6 et ses
deux pions peuvent s'avérer très fort et
créer un pion passé mais de l'autre côté
les noirs aussi un pion c5 qui est très
fort aussi puisqu'il est maintenant
soutenue par la tour c 8 et que protégé
par ses collègues à côté il peut aussi
créer un pion passé contre les deux
pions blancs ont été à leur avantage
d'avoir repris avec le pion c'est que ça
rend la main d'oeuvre du cavalier blanc
à 2 ridicule voilà ce qui est plus à
l'aise sur la case b4 puisque il ya le
pion c5 donc les blancs vont devoir
perdre du temps pour recycler vers le
sens de ce cavalier donc les
un homme prend des risques en laissant
pousser les pions sont au blanc mais en
même temps il ya des avantages aux coups
qu'il a fait du bien sûr de majorité va
se révéler la voilà c'est ça
effectivement il ya deux majorités comme
tu dis nicolas donkey majorité blanche
au centre une majorité noire sur les
dames mais qui a l'air forte parce que
les deux tours sont déjà en action puis
des pions sont déjà pas mal avancé des
pions sont pas mal avancé alors bondé
vite met en branle sa majorité tout de
suite avec le coût de 4,5 attaquant
lecavalier 6 anand sort le cavalier de
l'attak et le met sur la case 17 où il a
l'air de se décider de bloquer un petit
peu ses pions qui avance il n'avait pas
trop le choix ainsi venait sur la case
g4 il y avait le cou h3 qu'il repoussa
immédiatement un le courageux 3 ici qui
pouvait leur poussée il était obligé
d'agir la case 2 h 6 où il aurait été
peut nous voilà il restait la case aux 8
qui est vraiment triste donc donc c'est
la case la plus active finalement appelé
en même temps et elle est exposée aux
coups du pions blancs là qui va encore
s'avancer je crois exactement c'est le
coût que choisit yurevich avec eux six
ânes on devait quand même très en
confiance pour entrer dans une variante
aussi tendues que celle ci oui parce que
là ça affaiblit son rock maintenant j'ai
vite choisi l'attaqué à tout va il faut
qu'on attendait bien peser le pour et le
contre stratégiquement puisque là il va
il va prendre une ce qu'on appelle une
grosse attaque
surtout quand comme breivik qui est très
tactique il aime bien se défendre dans
les positions aiguë non j'ai déjà
remarqué contre adams dans leur match de
finale du challenger g des championnats
du monde
il ya eu un départage en partie de 25
minutes très très long parce qu'il
n'arrivait pas s'est il plaint deux nuls
mais parmi les nuls justement il ya eu
beaucoup de partis comme ça adams les
blancs qui attaque un homme qui se
défend et qui ne craque pas et qui
trouvent tous les bons coups défense et
qui prend le matériel quand on sacrifie
et
l'événement défenseur ans nanti d'un
très grand champion il n'a pas peur de
se défendre d'avoir son roi un peu dans
les courants d'air
donc là il me prend finalement le pion
aussi donc ça affaiblit un petit peu le
roi noir c'est là qu'on va voir
maintenant que morose et vite tu vas
tout balancer au niveau de l' attaque
puisqu'il va essayé d'activer au maximum
ses pièces pour jouer contre le roi noir
sachant que ce roi noir maintenant est
un petit peu isolé effectivement il ya
plus que deux pions devant lui pour le
protéger
puisque ceux qui ont maintenant f7 a
disparu et il ya des cases de
pénétration pour les cavaliers laquelle
gt5 qui est intéressante puisqu'il va
une case qui va pouvoir attaquer les
cases 6f 7
la dame b3 ici qui contrôle une
diagonale qui peuvent être très
dangereuses aussi et qu'il veut se faire
immédiatement bloqué comme la diagonale
par le coût du pillon voilà c'est à dire
que les noirs ont des contrôles menace
possible pour bloquer la diagonale ici
en tout cas on va voir comment ça se
passe ça va être édifié la commenter
parce que c'est très tactique maintenant
c'est très difficile à tous à tout voir
alors très tendu bon il choisit de ne
pas reprendre le 6 mai finalement de
sacrifier un jour le coup car les g5
finalement effectivement mais c'est une
manoeuvre d' attaque classique et en
poussant e6 et après la prise par les
noirs du pion il a conquis la case aussi
ce pour une pièce en fait accablant
exactement n'ya plus à les plus
contrôlées par le plus est la pulpe 9,7
pour le contrôle et donc cette case est
faible estime qu'aller là il sera très
fort ce cavalier puisqu'ils me
contrôleurs des classes tout près du
rang noir oui il ya aussi la tour qui
peut passer par là le pion enfin il ya
beaucoup de choix dans l' attaque on
retrouve un peu ce thème dans certaines
pire que oui absolument et une grande
variantes dans la pierre qui est avec
cette manoeuvre d' attaque alors l'un
d'eux choisi le coup cavaliers fuite ne
sait peut-être son idée qu'il avait vues
sur calais 17 ce cavalier est
excellemment placé je crois que on le
dit aussi souvent nicolas
dans les livres des chèques un cavalier
à côté du roi comme ça est un très bon
défenseur
oui absolument c'est l'ami du roi on dit
lecavalier et autant que l'on dit aussi
cavalier dames sont deux pieds attaque
très forte
oui absolument qu'on a droit donc le
cavalier l'ami des monarques finalement
oui c'est à dire que dame et cavaliers
dame fait toujours plus fou avec la
force du cavalier à côté de la dame
on peut prendre toutes les cases que
nous sommes tous très fort en avait 15
sur le diagonal sur les traverses et
plus les casses dits cavaliers donc on
contrôle tout un gros carnet copine trop
longs car et valier plus fort que le
couple est un fou parce que le couple
dame fou il y ajoute quelques fois le
même rôle là mais le fou ce qu'ils
contrôlent ils peuvent contrôler les
mêmes case les mêmes qui sont très
complémentaires
alors que dans les valises sont plus
complémentaires alors voyons la suite
maintenant puisqu'il faut avancer sinon
on va pas arriver à finir cette partie
le temps avance je vois alors cavaliers
c3 le cavaly finale revient maintenant
que l'individu avait menacé cette
manoeuvre de cavalli maintenant ils
remettraient très important nicolas
canton genre attaque on va de recycler
ces pièces oui absolument mais en pause
demandée pourquoi est-ce qu'il a pas
joué plutôt un coup comme dame f3 non ça
ne s'est pas suffisamment way maison
qu'avait le cavalier fluide pour le
centre qui protège bien s'est il faut
amener plus de place à l'attaqué donc
simon bonnes manoeuvres de vie de mort
évite vient de ramener ce caillou 2 qui
ne jouait plus ne jouez plus finalement
de [ __ ] les noirs ont mis leurs
fonctions ces 5 mai stipule que la
manoeuvre il était possible au ce qui me
gêne c'est qu'il bouche l'accès de la
dame serait troisième manche
effectivement on va voir qu'il va
réussir à réactiver tout ça
les noirs jouent le coup des cinq des
quatre eux-mêmes et là hop tout de suite
mon service ne prend pas en d4 mais
jouer ou cavalier a eu 4 a maintenant
une deuxième pièce à la taxe cavaliers
maintenant en quatre est aussi très bien
passé pour contrôler des cases pour
l'instant qui sont contrôlés quand ils
viennent par le pion ou sept
je crois qu'il a plus trop le choix non
plus puisque la majorité noire est en
train de s'enfoncer
il faut il faut faire un jeu de pièces à
mener toutes les pièces attaque oui
notez que s'il avait pris plus on prend
pion à b4 danois arrivé propose un
échange de dames ça faisait jouer la
tour noire etc
toutes les pièces noires avait de
l'activité alors qu'avec cac valeo 4 il
et vite que les pièces noires ne se
déchaînent trop vite alors là on va
avoir deux coups alors un coup h6 de 20
ans alors qui donc attaque maintenant le
cabinet 5
c'est un peu surprenant puisqu'on
pouvait l'impression qu' il pouvait
prendre à a3 oui c'est vrai mais
peut-être ce qu'avait prévu le rosé vite
c est maintenant la baisse d'avril à la
dame sur la case f3 en menaçant un échec
qui pourrait très embêtant sur la case
f7 oui parce que j'ai des menaces
possibles
tout à l'heure il y avait une défense
avec fouet 6 pour masquer de l'est
maintenant
sylvie de dame prend 1,6 effective et la
raison pour laquelle il joue papillon
prendra 3 la dame blanche menace de
venir à f3 donc il joue ayari jouez vous
montez vite mélomanes le cavalier blanc
voilà exactement mais mon davis ne fait
pas attention à secouer joue le coup des
six alors des six la loi c'est ça c'est
un coup vous hri fils de cavaillon mais
c'est un sacrifice de cavalli c'est beau
le cavalier si angers s'inquiètant prise
alors l'avantagé de ce coup c'est que ça
libère tout de suite la diagonale de la
dame voilà par contre on va mal l'idée
tout de suite parce que le pion aux six
est bien protégé par le cabinet fuite
donc pour l'instant la dame ne peut pas
prendre ce pion la menace par contre des
blancs c'est de prendre six avec
lecavalier mais on a l'impression qu'il
est noir pour reprendre angers 5
oui mais peut-être que le pion blanc va
continuer dans leur vie c'est exactement
alors peut-être un on va je vais enlever
un peu les plaies les flèches et alors
si les noirs prennent sur la case g5
ici le cas elle est peut-être le coup
des blancs ç'aurait pu comprendre cette
menace plus on prend un fluide dame
récupérant la pièce avec un roi noir qui
serait complètement aux fraises et celle
que rené blue bouge alors là il faudrait
bouger le cavalier par exemple sur la
case 17 grachev cette voie là j'ai
maintenant d'un prend aussi ses chèques
avec comme plus recette qui est énorme
attaque monstrueuse celui de cavaliers
des six oui c'est l'heureux leroy sera
obligé d'aller sur la case à chocs et
l'accueil des six qui menace une menace
de maths à l'étouffée très forte et
surtout et puis menace aussi de faire
dame menace de faire dame du pion donc
ça serait trop fort ça serait très fort
donc voilà l'idée de
demandez vite et qui quand une belle
idée qui prend toutes ses chances en
fait dans la semi rapide parce que ça
doit être très très très difficile a
tout calculé au point de prendre son
cavalier comme en ville de prendre moi
je leur ai pris je pense réunis pour
voir ou revoir et je crois que tu aurais
vie du jeu est là alors un an de choisi
un coût beaucoup plus sage
effectivement il prend pas mais il
pousse le pion en c4 ici et il bouche
ils bouchent la dame la dame ne sai ne
contrôle plus ça y est elle est bloquée
sur cette diagonale et si elle vient en
f3 il veut jouer de f5 c'est ça c'est ça
son idée département ainsi que celui ci
et blanc jours et joue la dame sur la
case f3 les noirs pour jouer eux mêmes
leurs dames à 5 sur la case f5 voilà
celle avantage ce coup-ci baissé mais
qu'as tu sais que ça libère la traverse
pour la dame noire
c'est un an pour revenir en défense une
défense qui a l'air très forte parce que
la lame noire contrôle beaucoup de cases
importante cinquième rang j'ai alors là
on s'est vite choisi le ku'damm h3 qui
est intéressant aussi puisque toujours
pareil sur la prise du cavaly des 5 des
cas légers scène pendant 11 jours et le
croupion prend 1,7 et on se retourne en
un grade puisque la dame h3 contrôlent
maintenant la case aussi si lecavalier
bouge on récupère aussi c'est avec échec
et donc avec une grosse attaque
à la différence que les lois pourraient
rendre la pièce de plus en jouant des
9,5 pour faire une finale pas clair
effectivement alors à nantes choisi huit
de prendre l'option des 6 et oui après
tout il n'ya pas trop de menaces donc et
moyens parce que son roi finalement en
tant que tant que ces pions reste bien
sage
ici le roi mais finalement il ya quand
même de l'espace pour ce pour se
protéger donc ils risquent pas encore
grand chose alors les cavaliers blanc
maintenant peuvent choisir le pion qui
vont capturés soit aussi soit des six
effectivement le cavalier ici donc à peu
prendre des six mais ça laisserait le
cavaly g5 emprise ou le qu'avec g5 peut
prendre six pour récupérer un pion
presse qui est plus offensif de prendre
réussissent thaler plusieurs fautes en
attaque contre le roi s'amuse et c'est
ce qu'a choisi effectivement de moreau
et beach fou prend cavaliers prendre le
6 alors peut-être avec une menace
positionnelle entre guillemets si on
peut dire parce que c'était très
tactique c'est d'échangés soit le
cavalier fuite certains défenseurs du
roi sur le cavalier suite soit
éventuellement même le fou g7 will
continue
viser le roi c'est sûr dans son style
alors attendre lui ne s'embarrasse pas
il a tout calculé l'impression c'est
l'impression qu'ils donnent y prend le
pion b2 et là il se crée tout de suite
et il n'a pas peur il n'a pas peur de
l'attaqué alors parce qu'il ya quand
même la dame qui attaquent le cavalier
aussi ce qui contrôlent des cases
dangereuse et le cavalier 4 qui contrôle
aussi la case m6 qui peut s'avérer très
dangereuse si le fou j'essaie de
savourer enfin se faisait changer
par contre ce que vient de faire un
aussi d'abord ils viennent enlever le
fou g7 de la deûle échanges possibles
mais il vient de se créer un million
gagnant des pions gagnants qu'à des
changes et c'est dire que là on est sûr
que l'un ou l'autre va gagner soit l'
attaque des blancs de passe soit c'est
carrément les noirs qui font dame mais
quand même et on a l'impression qu'il ya
des trous partout maintenant il vient
les croquer le pion qui en b2c quand
même mais surtout qu'on voit que là tu
remarques c'est surtout le pion à 6
science aaas on fout en fait le fou est
loin de soldats mais ils contrôlent des
cases pré de son roi quand même me
protège le roi noir mon avantage de
l'addu fu ces examens pour la distance
tout à fait mais il ya les seuls plans h
600 prises et ce monde il s'empresse de
prendre ce plan insiste on a une
pression ça y est ils donnent depuis on
le cavalier encore une fois on comprend
pas pourquoi ils donnent ce cavalier
alors effectivement il ya effectivement
le cavalier aussi ce qui est en prise
alors qu'est-ce qui se passerait sûr
mais tout simplement je crois qu'on a on
a calculé ça tout à l'heure nicolas en
quarts on va le voir tout de suite voit
ce qu'a calculé morozevich si les noirs
prennent le cavalier aussi ce cas les
rebonds tout simplement dame pranger 6
avec échec les couvre mettant le car il
est obligé de revenir sinon les blancs
récupère le cavalier avec une avec un
roi qui serait complètement à l'air et
une attaque probablement gagnante car
elle j'ai cette force et est maintenant
cavalier j5 menace imparable pour les
blancs je ne sais pas d'âme f5 non il ya
effectivement d'art et 5 en coupe on
avait peut-être pas envisagé nicolas
d'un médecin qui a l'air de protéger et
pourtant il doit bien y avoir quelque
chose dans cette version c'est peut-être
pas c'est peut-être pas calé j'ai c'est
que l'on pensé à calais g5 mais c'était
pas le coup peut-être cavaliers prend
des six
peut-être cavale et prendre des six
effectivement qu'elle allait prendre des
six je sais pas c'est possible ça
attaque ça fait pas ça a pas l'air de ça
pas l'air de ces fortes un peu peut-être
la menace et dans ce cas là pour être de
toros est peut-être nicolas il peut
faire fou prend tout a un sens qu'on
voit vraiment l'inconvénient on va
revenir peut-être le coup d'avant ont
alors mis dans le coup d'avant est tout
à fait non la dame mais c'est pas ça
qu'elle désire pas entrer dans cette
voie là c'est ça s'il avait joué
cavalier prend cavaliers
donc il faudrait revenir sur ce coup-là
week-end à l'époque cavalli non mais
c'est déjà la ligne indiquait alors la
bonde armp rampillon échec
ça semble doté par les pentes des six
tout simplement je crois pas je crois
pas ça rate un certain que lecavalier
aussi c'est quand même vrai mais au fait
cavalier g7 ah oui à ce moment-là tour
au quoique non c'est un de ces coups là
bien sûr qu'il aurait il suffit de il
suffit de il peut peut-être joué aussi
alors l'ordinateur propose le coût d'un
projet six en tout cas c'est ce que dans
les ordinateurs mais avait quand même un
gros avantage moi un gros avantage aux
avantages mans donc ça serait du bluff
ce serait du bluff d'accord aussi ce
qu'il faut noter c'est que on est en
partie rapide
ah oui et peut-être voilà le facteur
très important et les joueurs sont
probablement en fin de temps il faut
savoir intimider l'adversaire par
exactement c'est à dire que là il ya on
voit pas de solution et l'ordinateur non
plus donc on peut supposer qu
effectivement il y en a pas on en avait
pensé à une ligne mais qui ne s'avère
pas bonne peut-être qu'un an de 6 à vue
cette ligne là puis m'a trouvé une plus
sur wii avons dû prendre moins de
risques peut-être parce qu'il n'était
pas sûr peut-être de lui tout est
possible aussi oui il est chaude et déjà
par plusieurs défaites contes moraux et
beach dans ce genre de partie où il
parlait du granby du roi tout à l'heure
il n'a pas envie de bien pas envie de
revenir ça crée une nouvelle fois en
tout cas donc c'était un groupe aussi
probablement car les cavaliers aussi si
ya pas a priori de réfutation clair et
en tout cas
l'ordinateur le confirme qu un très joli
coup nikaïa peut-être si je viens de
voir une idée
je ne vois rien ne dit qu'on est à moins
de ses cavaliers f6 échec
les gérants et tout reprend 1,6 le coup
d'après peut-être avec madame jourdain
9,55 à 9,5 alors d'en prendre six
maintenant damage 5 de la part des noirs
protection ça y est ça ça c'est un coût
qui est joli souvent le nicolas qu'on
voit pas on dit souvent les coups
transversaux et les travées travers les
traverses et ça c'est une très jolie
coûte défense la dame qui était
complètement à côté l'échiquier revient
à la défense de son roi est un peu
esseulé
oui mais s'il ya échange des dames on a
dit tout à l'heure les pions noirs et
gagner oui c'est peut-être ça c'est que
ce que cydia nantes c'est que je suis
tellement gagnant que tous les coups
gagnants
finalement il faut pas prendre de risque
avec un roi trop à la menace est donc la
taille de noémie s'avère pas
suffisamment forte
malgré la menace que ça représentait on
a vu qu'on aurait pu trébucher plusieurs
fois alors ça c'est la partie la partie
pas terminée manger vite ou encore le
ku'damm e3 mais on voit ça y est qu'il
est repoussée quand même entre le
ku'damm 3 il est quand même bien
repoussé c'est vrai alors il prendra le
cavalier non il le prend à nantes fini
par le prendre
finalement c est qu est-ce qui jouent
alors maintenant ils jouent qu'à aller
prendre des si c'est un petit peu la
rendre compte disiez tout à l'heure avec
un coup de moins le coup d'un match 5 et
le ku'damm e3 peut-être cavaliers six
échecs c'était intéressant non il faut
prendre un coup franc et 29,5 endroit g7
j'essaie d'aider cet échec il ya une
série déjà une série d'échecs mais ça
m'a pris pas loin à prévoir si ça ne va
pas très loin
alors maintenant après qu'elle prendrait
si ce n'est à attendre et choisi de
remettre son cavalier à côté du roi on
sait que il attaque et voilà c'est l'ami
du roi
il revient voir son copain une fois en
fait il a fait le
le marché ouais il donne volontiers sa
tour parce que ce qui est important
c'est les pions noirs la cci noir qui
sont trop forts ces cartes et b4 ses
pions sur tous ceux qui ont ces quatre
kilomètres à l'est effectivement adam
sans opposant l'homme est énormément aux
élites choisi de jouer torah d un il
continue de bluff un petit peu de
l'attak il essaie de ramener des pièces
à l'attack qu'il a d'autres est-ce qu'il
a pas grand chose il faut qu'ils jouent
le tout pour le tout la b prend 1,3 à
sailly alors un an d'un karim assayas
trop d'options gagne en quoi c'est sûr
que là ses pions vont adam est ici mon
avis je ne trouve pas un math c'est
terminé oui on voit d'ailleurs pas
d'échec au roi noir que puisse faire
morose et vite on a l'impression que
c'est terminé l attaque contre le roi
noir beach avec la dame qui défend assez
bien le fou qui défend de loin le
cavalier on voit pas trop comment les
blancs vont prendre le fou qui protège
bien son camp la dame qui protège bien
aussi je crois les cases autour du roi
ça va aller très vite à partir de ces
cas sont safe donc le roi et risquent
pas grand chose qu'on a dans son coin
alors il ya dams est peut-être pour
aller faire échec dans les sectes loisy
d'un f4 voilà madame f4 qui menacent si
on peut dire un échec
henri vii mais qui ne encore une fois
qu'il prête pas à conséquence puisque le
après les cases noires sont protégés
donc après que le roi va sur la case à
schwyz
il est tranquille alors faut qu'on
finisse pas ce qu'il nous reste plus qu'
on sait très peu de temps il reste deux
minutes
donc après tour c'est cette du côté noir
il ya en même temps se soustraire la
tour à la tête du cavalier exactement
sept tours protège excellent herman
toute la rangée donc on voit que la nand
et tranquille quoi il a vraiment tous
les atouts de son côté et maintenant il
est à toutes les pièces qu'ils défendent
parfaitement sombre donc mon envie de
continuer c'est de tenter d'intimider de
bousculer l'adversaire par un coup de
pions qui attaquent la dame adverse avec
le coup j'ai quatre ânes on ne remet
saddam en défense on voit toutes les
pièces sont très très bien
mise en défens sûr que là c'est du béton
la position d'un an
il faut remarquer c'est la force du fou
qui défend de loin son roi c'est
toujours pareil ce serait une leçon de
défense de la distance la mongie vite
choisi le coup joué le goût d'un
cavalier 1,8 à qui crée une petite
menace sur la tour c 7 mai un an de seul
est égal il sait très bien que cette
tourne donc une importance est la
dernière pièce d'attac des blanches non
parce que attention les deux tours
n'arriveront pas faire grand chose
la menace est peut-être aussi de pouvoir
les henry cissé en fin d'échangés le fou
g7 oui mais restera il restera toujours
le cavalier fuite qui protégera très
bien droit à l'ami du roi c'est vrai
alors il faut terminer avec tours d2 de
la part de mme rose est vite et après
damev 7
ça y est mon avis tu abandonnes il
arrête là les frais ils voient que les
noirs sont très bien défendus et c'est
que maintenant le prochain coup des
dénonça sera probablement d'avancé soit
le pion à 2 d'ailleurs semblent soit le
pion c4 qui vont donc aller à dame
soutenu par par leur tour enquêtes qui
sont très bien placés donc là c'est une
leçon de sang froid je crois d'un angle
défense extraordinaire quelques moments
on a l'impression que le roi noir et on
n'a pas le temps de finir soit nicolas
de l'habitude qui leur est peut-être
parler de 18 matches qui a eu la
simultanée entre des sports oui alors
qu'oscar enfin jouer contre sting à new
york effectivement le chanteur contre le
band de sting et 30 personnes en
personne à peu près donc ceci bien que
ça si près c'est à new york que ça fait
beaucoup de bruit s'est passé sur cnn
c'était très labatut qui veut et
trompettiste il a battu les batteurs il
a battu tout le monde alors on essaie
cul nul tu deviens le temps qu on finit
sur cette bonne note de kasparov contre
sting voilà je crois que on a passé une
belle partie je crois que c'était
intéressant de la commenter
c'est très belle leçon de défense merci
à vous deux
vous dire la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle émission de des bonheurs
oh